ah however these contestants reacted to
you if they freaked out a little bit
getting to me I think I'm more nervous
than they are there are 20 contestants
left but only 14 will make it to the
next round that's where Jason Mraz
Shaggy and Bret young are among the
celebs duetting with these Idol hopefuls
we're doing I need your love which is a
very happy is very islands off do you
ever attire performance no an icon Luke
Bryan Katy Perry how's that gonna feel
for you it's gonna be really fun but
then you walk out on the stage and you
know they have more at stake but still
you're like wow I'm nervous right
what kind of advice are you giving them
having the experience that you do have
I just always tell them to be themselves
be authentic
if they can figure out how to really tap
into their true love and the true
emotion and just bring that to the stage
they'll they'll have no problems I -
speaking of true love newly engaged
Katie and Orlando are working out the
details of their wedding no date yet but
maybe they can hire the entertainment
maybe you sing a little love song for
her in Orlando I don't know play the
weddings Orlando is that her spouse okay
you said you are removed from the
Hollywood sorry Congrats
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]